hey guys in this video i'm going to show
you how and why you should cuff your
pants and that's not just for jeans but
for any pens you wear
let me explain why you should do it
number one if you cough your pants you
can perfectly adjust the pants to fit in
with the length of your legs number two
it is stylish
the pants won't hang sloppy over your
ankles but it will look tapered and it
will look especially good if you are a
fan of fashion socks and want to show
them off number three you can cuff them
in a way that would make your pants fit
in with your ankle size for example i
have skinny ankles and that is why my
pants always look baggy than there and
coughing them correctly is an easy fix
alright so let me show you how to cuff
your pants according to your body shape
let's get to
[Music]
it just very quick it's the first time
that you hear my channel my name is
daniel and welcome to dlm men's
lifestyle if you haven't subscribed yet
please consider it so you won't miss any
of our future videos and the ones we
already have
now let's start with number one
[Music]
all right guys now the fastest and
easiest way to cuff your pants is
the simple roll
all you do is fold it up one to four
times depending on your height for
example if you're a short guy you might
roll it up a few times more than taller
guys it's super easy and it's perfect
for big guys with bigger ankles but for
guys who's a bit more skinnier skinnier
ankles like me
it always falls down if that happens to
you you can do number two
[Applause]
[Music]
just use a rubber band so do the simple
roll but get the band in there to hold
it in place
easy isn't it
now some guys prefer to smooth out the
cuff a little bit more to make it more
flat even kind of perfect
um i don't really like that um it's your
choice i like it more uneven rough
rugged
because i don't want to look that
perfect but the choice is yours
now the pin roll
this is honestly the best way to cuff
your pants according to your ankle size
all you need to do is fold it over the
inseam of the leg vertically hold it
with your thumb and fold it up normally
two to four times it will look nicely
tapered and it will stay in place now
the width of the roll that of course
depends on you it depends on what you
like what you prefer and that of course
goes for the simple roll as well
you can try the single cuff which is of
course a single cuff of about four to
five centimeters
the iron worker or some call it the mega
cuff which is just one big cuff about
eight to twelve centimeters this is
better with rugged boots
then there's a skinny roll
which is just a very thin cuff rolled up
two to four times this works really well
with pants that are tight
another one is the japanese cuff
this works great with denims and all you
do is roll one big cuff of around nine
centimeters and then a smaller single
cuff on top of that so that the first
one sticks out a bit
oh and this is one of my favorites if
it's summer you feel hot
this is what you do and you just go and
you let loose
[Music]
the summer cuff
you gotta roll up your pants in an
uneven manner two to four times and it
can be above your ankles if you want
this is just a manly casual look that
basically says
i want to have fun that's why i like it
so much
now if you're new here to the channel
watch one of these videos here you might
like it and always remember this life is
short so don't waste yours cheers guys